Thomas Cashman guilty of the murder
murder of Olivia Pratt Corbell at her
home in Liverpool last August the story
we will all remember of course guilty in
fact on all five counts that he faced
the first charge the murder of Olivia
Pratt Corbell a charge of attempted
murder of the the intended target that
night according to the prosecution uh
wounding with intent of Olivia's mother
Cheryl who was shot through the hand the
bullet to pass through her hand was the
one that fatally wounded Olivia and two
charges of firearms possession as well
the jury went out at about 12 o'clock
yesterday so four hours of deliberation
yesterday another three today and
they've come back with those verdicts
and for certainly for Olivia's family
who have been in court throughout this
trial there will be a significant sense
of relief as you can imagine guilty on
all charges Thomas Cashman our crime
correspondent Martin brunt is with me
and and the jury convinced by that
prosecution case mark yes and it wasn't
the strongest prosecution case there
were no there was no forensic evidence
there was nobody who saw what happened
and could identify Thomas Cashman
and for a long time police found it
difficult to to get the evidence that
detectives normally strive for in in
these kind of cases but eventually they
did find evidence people did come
forward I was talking to somebody from
Crime Stoppers a couple of days ago who
said that because of that big reward 200
000 pounds eventually that a phenomenal
amount of information did eventually
come in Cashman we know was arrested
within about what two weeks of the
shooting but then was released on bail
and it was another three nearly a month
before he was rearrested and then
charged it's difficult to know what part
the 2000 200 000 pound reward played but
clearly it did persuade some people to
come forward good with information but
of course the key witness in this was
the woman who Cashman had had an on off
fling with she came forward very quickly
and gave what I think must have proved
The crucial evidence against him by
saying that sometime quickly after the
shooting Cashman turned up at her house
asked for a change of clothes and most
crucially of all she says that she
overheard him on the phone saying I've
done Joey a reference that the
prosecution said was a reference to him
shooting Joe Joseph knee who was the
first man who was shot and then pursued
and then the last shot was the one that
went through the door of the Corbell
family and hit and killed Olivia so that
crucial evidence I think must have
played a vital part in the jury's
deliberations the other evidence from
the prosecution
circumstantial not Direct evidence but
it was all about cashman's movements on
the day before the shoot the day of the
shooting
passing several times the house where he
thought Joseph knee was going to be and
was later that evening where he was
followed from that house but the
prosecution case was that kashmas was
looking for Joseph knee to shoot him
which is what he did some hours later
Cashman was shown to be wearing similar
clothing to the gunman
he was found to have dismantled CCTV at
his own home a couple of days after the
shooting prosecution said this was so
that his movements couldn't be tracked
he disposed of his own phone two days
before the shooting again said the
prosecution this was evidence of a man
planning to do a shooting and getting
get trying to get rid of any evidence
that might point to his guilt
subsequently you mentioned that arrested
and I think we have some video now that
the police have released uh body camera
footage from one of the officers
involved in that arrest of Thomas
Cashman at his home in in runcorn we can
play that now for you
[Music]
sits on your ass
yourself
one little bit I just want to know what
I've done that's all
all I wanna know
tell me what I'm resting for
honey
and a suspicion of attempt murder twice
you do not have to say anything
of course
okay okay
foreign
so that body camera footage there of the
arrest of Thomas Cashman at his home a
couple of weeks after uh the death of
Olivia that that body camera footage was
shown to the jury during the course of
this uh trial it was a huge and
extremely complex investigation as
Martin Brum was saying where the police
had very little forensic evidence for
example and a huge team of officers
dealing with a with an investigation
that of course aroused massive public
interest not just in in Liverpool but
around the country and and for the
investigating team and the senior
investigating officer detective
superintendent uh Mark Baker this will
be a moment of huge relief after that
investigation
please we got Justice for them after all
this uh length of time
and I mentioned before the dignity they
show through the course of trial
particularly Shadow having to relive the
instance again
must have been
unbelievable I I will never know when
nor will any member of the investigation
team what she had to go through
um and that's the same for father as
well Dad Sean prepared of them
uh we'll never understand exactly what
they've gone through and nor should we
even try
I've been police nearly 30 years and so
with colleagues
probably never been involved with
anything quite like that if I'm going to
be honest the circumstances around it
were just
abundance
and she was cowering behind them all
because she was scared in her own home
he always feel as though you're safe in
your own house
I think as an investigation team we
could not believe
that the government would continue to
shoot into the house
I don't think we've ever seen anything
like that before
people have been shot on the street
but when he pursued Joseph knee into the
house
particularly that fourth shot that went
through the front door
he will have heard her scream we can
hear it other jewelry did
and then he's gone into the house again
and continue to shoot I think
that act really shocked all the
investigation team and the whole
community
that was a rise
in
recklessness that probably we've never
seen before as an investigation team we
did feel the pressure
you can't not because we all live and
work
in merseyside
merseyside's a very very small place
and wherever you turned people were
talking about this we were very focused
as an investigation team we were
supported from the whole by the whole of
law enforcement because such was the
outrage that this crime an investigation
generated
Community have been discussed
by his actions
they've been in fear of him for a long
long time
he will know himself
and had to carry that responsibility he
couldn't own up to it
s family and some of his associates
will also look at themselves
and wonder whether they could have done
anything more